-We're here with Chris Hayes.
You wrote a fascinating piece
in "The New Yorker"
about Internet, about celebrity,
about surveillance,
and just in general
the idea of fame
and how there's less gateways
to fame than ever before.
But there's a great price
that is incurred on people.
Can you speak to your thesis?
-Yeah, I mean, I think
that what has happened is
that the experience of having
someone you don't know know you,
a stranger seeing you,
knowing you, surveilling you,
is fundamentally alien
and alienating.
It's fundamentally outside
the normal portfolio
of human experience, right?
We're designed to have
kin relationships
and then maybe
there's some king somewhere
that we know about, right,
or there's some god
in the pantheon.
But to have strangers
know about you,
which is what social media
has introduced to everyone,
really psychologically
can be quite toxic.
And I think -- You know,
I said in the piece
that in the same way
that electricity
went from a kind of thing
only the elite had
to being accessible to everyone,
I think that experience
of strangers knowing about you,
responding to you, you know,
saying something about you,
looking at your picture,
that used to be
a very small group of people
had that experience,
people like yourself or me
or people that were
in the public eye.
And it's now been
kind of democratized
in ways that I think
is wreaking real psychological
and social havoc in ways that
we haven't fully appreciated.
And you sort of are honest
about the fact
that you're somebody
who can put something out there
and one negative comment
would sort of eradicate
a thousand positive comments.
-Yeah, and I think that math
is true for a lot of people.
I mean, maybe
I'm just a snowflake.
[ Both laugh ]
But I think that we are --
Again, we're conditioned to
think about these relationships
as being the relationships with
the people that we love, right?
It's like you want the approval
and the affection
and the respect of people
that you love and respect,
and then if there's
like some rando
who says something mean to you,
you're processing that
psychologically
as if that was a person
you loved and respected.
And it takes a lot of willpower
and training, I think,
psychologically
to get rid of that.
But I think about being a
teenager under those conditions,
because that's already the case
of teenage life
is you're very worried about
people's perception of you.
You're very much
forming your identity.
And then it's like
everyone in the world
can see you at that moment.
There's something
happening there
that I think
is pretty unnerving.
-With that said, you wrote
this piece for "The New Yorker."
You put it out in the world.
Did you immediately look
to read comments?
-Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, yeah.
I was just, like, following.
I was just like --
I was just like a junkie
looking for the dopamine hit.
Like, "Yes, yes, yes."
Approval of strangers.
They like the piece.
-Well, I know
I'm not a stranger,
but I like the piece
a great deal, as well.
And it's always a pleasure
having you come upstairs.
Thanks for being back.
-Thanks.
-Chris Hayes, everybody.
"All In" airs weeknights
at 8:00 on MSNBC.
You can listen to
"Why Is This Happening?"
wherever you get your podcasts.